bonsoir à toutes et à tous je m'appelle
nda tout d'abord je vais vous demander
de faire preuve d'indulgence
parce que je ne suis pas une spécialiste
de la communication ni une conférencière
professionnels je suis ici parce qu'on
m'a invité à parler de mon parcours qui
est étroitement liée à l'esprit critique
si je devais définir la personne que je
suis en quelques mots je pourrais dire
que je je suis une solitaire solidaire
pourquoi solitaire parce que depuis tout
petit j'ai toujours ressenti ce
sentiment de solitude et solidaire parce
que je suis une personne empathique et
j'ai toujours aimé aider les autres si
je devais résumer mon parcours en
quelques mots je dirais que ces parcours
d'une combattante
pourquoi une combattante parce que je me
suis toujours battu dans ma vie comme
beaucoup de gens mais ce que je ne
savais pas c'est que le combat le plus
difficile
j'allais le mener contre moi même donc
je vais essayer de vous résumer en
plusieurs parties mon histoire c'est pas
évident mais mais en tout cas c'est
l'objectif
ce que je peux dire c'est que tout au
long de ma vie cette solitude m'a
accompagné et puis un jour je me suis
rendu compte que je n'étais pas si seul
en fait j'ai toujours eu un allié un
allié fidèle un compagnon de route
qu'ils allaient me guider à prendre des
décisions importantes dans des moments
cruciaux de ma vie et ce compagnon de
route
devinez comment il s'appelle bah c'est
l'esprit critique et je vais vous
expliquer pourquoi
c'est mon fidèle allié en fait je vais
commencer par le commencement c'est à
dire ma naissance je suis né à rouen en
76 je suis un enfant de la colonisation
en fait mais mes deux parents quitter
leur pays d'origine contre leur gré mon
père était algérien il a quitté
l'algérie à cause de la guerre d'algérie
où il a été torturé
ma mère
tunisienne a quitté son pays natal à
cause d'un mariage forcé avec mon père
et donc moi je suis arrivé en france en
à rouen en 76 je suis né d'un couple
mixte issu d'un mariage forcé et on peut
pas dire que je sois arrivé dans ce
monde dans les meilleures circonstances
très tôt le mariage a pris fin entre mes
deux parents et donc je suis devenu un
enfant du divorce
donc étant donné que mes parents
n'étaient pas de la même origine mon
père a refait sa vie avec une femme de
la même origine que lui et ma mère a
refait sa vie avec un homme de la même
origine et je me suis retrouvé tout seul
au milieu de deux clans de deux familles
quand j'allais chez mon père on disait
tiens voilà la tunisienne
et quand j'allais chez ma mère on disait
celle là elle est algérienne donc très
tôt j'ai souffert de ce sentiment de
rejet de parler d'autres et je peux dire
que j'ai subi le racisme au sein de ma
propre famille mais j'ai subi aussi
d'autres maltraitance j'ai subi le
l'abandon de mon père quelque part parce
que c'était très compliqué pour lui qui
avait refait sa vie et j'ai subi les
maltraitances violente de ma mère j'ai
subi d'autres choses je j'ai subi des
abus sexuels et ça a démarré très tôt en
classe de cp
mon maître d'école pendant deux ans nous
faisait subir des attouchements puis à
l'âge de 9 ans je suis parti en vacances
en tunisie comme chaque année avec ma
mère est là j'ai subi une tentative de
viol par mon cousin
à ce moment là ma réaction a été de
devenir un garçon manqué c'était une
manière de me préserver du regard des
hommes est aussi une manière de en fait
de faire comprendre que cette féminité
en fait était un problème
donc je ne voulais pas comment considère
comme une fille je préférerais qu'on
regarde comme un garçon parce que
j'avais compris très tôt que ça allait
être compliqué d'être une fille au sein
d'une famille musulmane
en fait j'aurais préféré être un garçon
est finalement malgré cette enfance
difficile
j'ai continué mon petit chemin de vie et
j'étais une enfant très curieuse donc je
m'intéressais beaucoup à la lecture dont
je lisais toutes sortes de livres que je
trouvais j'étais passionné à l'école
j'étais une fille très vive et donc tout
ça m'a aidé à développer mon esprit
critique et en fait ce que je ne savais
pas c'est que l'esprit critique allait
devenir un véritable allié à partir de
là à l'âge de 20 ans je prends la
décision une des décisions les plus
importantes de ma vie quand je pars en
vacances en tunisie
ma mère décide de me marier et pour la
première fois de ma vie je dis non je me
révolte et je m'enfuis jeu je réussi à
fuir un mariage qu'on voulait m'imposer
finalement je me retrouve en france et à
partir de là je suis tout seul je
m'inscris à la fac et donc je décide à
la fac de me voiler je décide de porter
le voile parce que je n'accepte toujours
pas cette féminité qui me fait peur je
considère tous les hommes comme des
pervers sexuels et j'ai l'impression que
le voile en fait tu vas me protéger du
regard masculin et va aussi permettre à
m à ma mère de comprendre que sa fille
est une fille sérieuse et qui n'est elle
n'est pas celle qu'elle croit et donc à
ce moment là le voile est une véritable
protection parce qu'en fait je passe du
garçon manqué à la fille voilée encore
une manière de renier ma féminité ce qui
se passe c'est que dès que je porte le
voile
donc c'est un petit voile on me met en
lien avec un homme qui est salafistes
qui deviendra mon mari parce que je pars
en vacances en tunisie et
je me retrouve marié du jour au
lendemain avec un homme que je connais
pas i les salafistes et il se présente
comme un sorte de guide de sauveur il
m'explique que le vrai islam c'est le
salafisme et à partir de là donc je
deviens une épouse et rapidement une
maman je sors de la vie d'adolescente
pour devenir aussitôt une épouse une
femme soumise et une maman en fait je
peux dire que c'était aussi quelque part
une manière de fuir ce pass est demeuré
paré d'une enfance qui a été abîmée et
fragilisé j'étais une proie facile
à ce moment là et c'est pour ça quelque
part que j'ai fait aussi ce choix parce
que j'aurais pu m'enfuir mais j'ai
accepté la servitude volontaire et donc
je me retrouve rapidement maman est
enfermé coupés du monde pendant presque
dix ans sans télé sans radio plus aucune
sortie en fait mon ex-mari m'expliquer
la société mécréante et notre ennemi les
mécréants les juifs tous ces gens là ce
sont nos ennemis et rapidement je suis
embrigader et je crois à tout ça donc je
deviens moi même tout ce que je ne
voulais pas être finalement une personne
qui a de la haine pour les autres une
personnes intolérantes parce qu'on a
l'impression qu'on fait partie du groupe
sauvé et que cette vie ne vaut rien que
cette vie et la prison du croyant pour
les salafistes et qu'il faut préparer sa
vie après la mort et pour ça il faut
obéir totalement à son époux et être
dans totale soumission ce que j'accepte
et donc pendant toutes ces années
donc je suis maman j'élève mes enfants
je suis une épouse dévouée totalement
soumise et mon esprit critique et sans
est en sommeil jusqu'au jour presque dix
ans après le mariage il ya un sursaut il
ya un déclic
ce déclic c'est une question que je pose
à mon mari parce que je suis toujours
aussi curieuse et là je demande à mon
mari est ce que le djihad est
obligatoire et mon mari me dit oui bien
sûr que le djihad et obligatoires du 10
mai mais ça veut dire quoi est-ce que
nous nos deux fils devront aller faire
le djihad un jour on me dit bien sûr je
suis dit mais attends mais et toi est-ce
que pourquoi tu ne fais pas le jihad si
le djihad est obligatoire
pourquoi tu vas pas aller
ces pauvres enfants qu'on voit en sang
en palestine contre cc contre les juifs
qui les assassine il me dit mais non le
djihad est obligatoire mais moi je n'ai
je ne peux pas je dois m'occuper de ma
famille est ensuite julie et pour notre
fille alors il me dit mais notre fille
portera le voile à l'âge de sept ans et
on l'a mariera à 14 ans et ce soir là
j'ai pas dormi de la nuit parce que
toute la nuit je me suis dit mais c'est
pas possible j'ai pas porté mes enfants
neuf mois pour en faire des jihadistes
pour en faire de la chair à canon et
j'ai pas envie que ma fille portent le
voile à 7 ans soit mariée à 14 ans et
subissent ce que moi j'ai subi et en
fait c'est à ce moment là que il ya eu
une sorte de réveil et que je me suis
dit mais il faut absolument que je fasse
quelque chose je peux pas continuer
comme ça parce que nous avions prévu de
partir en arabie saoudite et en fait ce
qui s'est passé c'est que le jour où mon
mari est parti au consulat d'arabie
saoudite pour faire les papiers pour le
départ définitif en arabie saoudite
eh bien j'ai eu un un vrai sursaut
j'ai pris mes trois enfants j'ai pris un
taxi j'ai pris quelques affaires et je
suis parti à 7 heures du matin sur la
route de la liberté
je suis parti armand pour retrouver ma
liberté et j'ai retrouvé ma liberté à
partir de ce jour nager j'ai eu le
divorce
un an après ça a été compliqué parce que
mon mari me menacer me disais que chez
nous on devait une femme ne devait pas
demander le divorce et que si elle osé
faire cela il faut lesquelles on la tue
elle mérite elle méritait d'être égorgé
ma famille m'avait tourné le dos parce
que chez nous ça ne se fait pas de
divorcer et donc je me suis retrouvée
toute seule avec trois enfants avec le
voile comme une sorte d' handicapé
social
je ne connaissais pas les codes de la
société vous découvrez un monde que je
ne connaissais pas avant puisque
j'allais passer ma vie enfermé au début
chez ma mère est ensuite un mari qui
était devenu mon geôlier dans une prison
à ciel ouvert et ce qui se passe à ce
moment là c'est que j'ai l'impression de
conduire une voiture sans permis et je
ne sais pas où je vais donc c'est très
compliqué parce que je sombre rapidement
dans la précarité
je n'ai jamais travaillé de ma vie je
porte le voile je n'ai aucune confiance
en moi
et rapidement ma situation se complique
je tombe dans la déprime je suis isolé
et puis finalement je perds la garde de
mes enfants parce que je sujet des
problèmes de santé et pendant deux ans
mon ex-mari m'empêche de voir mes
enfants
il réussit à me séparer de mes enfants
et là je sombre je coule littéralement
je n'ai plus aucun goût de vivre et en
fait dans un geste de désespoir je fini
par aller voir une assistante sociale
je lui demande madame qu'est ce que je
dois faire pour retrouver mes enfants et
elle m'explique en fait pour retrouver
vos enfants c'est simple faut avoir un
appartement pour avoir un appartement
faut avoir un travail des fiches de
saïda de salaire et ce qui se passe
c'est qu'à ce moment là je comprends que
le voile est une barrière que je ne
pourrais pas continuer comme ça c'est
compliqué en france de trouver un boulot
avec le voile quand je sors dans la rue
je je me sens rejeté par les regards des
uns et des autres je suis rejetée par ma
propre communauté les salafistes et
finalement je décide de me faire
violence dans un geste d'amour envers
mes enfants pour pouvoir les retrouver
et je je je retire ce voile et
finalement je me rends compte qu'en fait
d'avoir retiré le voile ferment un mal
pour un bien parce que grâce à ça je
trouve rapidement un emploi et je me re
sociabilise et je commence à réapprendre
à vivre normalement
je travaille je gagne mon premier
salaire et je commence à retrouver une
estime de moi c'est à dire que je me dis
je suis capable de faire quelque chose
de gagner mon propre argent et en plus
je commence à voir des amis et ce qui se
passe à ce moment là c'est que je gagne
ce pari parce que je m'étais juré de
retrouver mes enfants et en 2011 je
retrouve la garde de mes enfants
et dans la foulée je trouve un travail
je suis recruté au ministère de la
justice comme greffière ce qui se passe
à ce moment là c'est que je me pose
beaucoup de questions parce que pendant
les deux ans où j'ai pas eu mes enfants
j'ai fait beaucoup de recherches pour
combler le vide de l'absence de mes
enfants je faisais des recherches un peu
partout notamment sur le net sur les
réseaux sociaux sur différents sujets
qui m'intriguait qui m'intriguait sur le
complotisme sur le salafisme sur la
servitude volontaire
ou encore la malbouffe est en fait tout
ça ça a permis de réveiller mon esprit
critique encore une fois et finalement
un jour je me dis je peux pas je suis
pas bien je ne peux pas continuer comme
ça je dois trouver une solution parce
que je culpabilise d'avoir retiré le
voile est en fait c'est à ce moment là
que je me tourne vers un homme que je
considérais comme le porte parole des
musulmans modérés en france un sorte de
guide pour moi
et malheureusement pour moi ce guide
allait rapidement devenir mon bourreau
puisque j'ai malheureusement subi un
viol un viol auquel je n'étais je m'y
attendais pas je ne pensais pas que cela
m'arriverait à moi j'étais encore une
proie à ce moment là et ce qui se passe
après c'est que je garde le silence
parce que je culpabilise et j'ai honte
et je sais que personne ne me croira je
me dis que c'est moi la responsable et
puis il y à un quelque chose d'important
qui se passe et qu'ils changent d'avis
encore une fois c'est les attentats du
bataclan à partir du moment où il ya eu
les attentats du bataclan il ya eu un
grand sursaut jeu réalisé à quel point
le salafisme pouvait être un danger pour
ce pays pour les gens pour moi pour tout
le monde pour mes enfants et finalement
je me dis je dois prendre ma
responsabilité et je dois parler je dois
dénoncer parce que je connais le
salafisme de l'intérieur et à ce moment
là je décide de prendre la parole
publiquement de dénoncer le salafisme de
dénoncer le terrorisme de dénoncer le
voile imposé et de parler de tous les
sujets qui me révolte
et là je tombe rapidement dans une
spirale médiatique on me propose
d'écrire mon histoire dans un livre et
on me propose de parler et de parler et
de lancer une association
je lance une association que j'appelle
libératrice parce que mon objectif c'est
d'aider les autres femmes et finalement
je suis ultra médiatisé et puis au bout
d'un moment il y à la ferme itou émis
tout c'est de cette grande vague de
libération de la parole des femmes
victimes de l'abus sexuel et à ce moment
là je décide
de prendre la parole et de briser un
tabou dans la communauté musulmane c'est
le viol
je donne le nom de mon agresseur c'est
une personne connue un prédicateur connu
et à ce moment là je suis emporté dans
un tourbillon médiatique
je suis menacé menacé de mort je suis
harcelé et puis il ya des centaines des
milliers de personnes qui me soutiennent
qu'ils me trouve courageuse et à ce
moment là je me forge un personnage de
victimes c'est à dire que je continue à
parler de moi mais en tant que victime
parce que j'ai besoin de cette
reconnaissance de mon statut de victime
est au bout d'un certain temps je fais
le tour des plateaux télé le tour des
médias je côtoie je côtoie des
politiques des journalistes ce monde là
et je me dis j'espère que ces gens là
vont m'aider mais malheureusement pour
moi
encore une fois c'est une idée les
désillusions je suis très déçu parce que
des choses n'avancent pas je suis pas
heureuse et puis on met pas à faire
avancer mon association est en fait je
me rends compte que c'est parce que tout
simplement j'étais encore dans ce statut
de victime qui avait besoin du soutien
extérieur et finalement ça a été un
déclic pour moi parce que à un moment
donné j'ai fait les bonnes rencontres
j'ai fait encore mon autocritique et ça
m'a permis de comprendre que le problème
venait de moi et pas du monde extérieur
et que les solutions allaient venir de
moi n'y pas du monde extérieur
c'est à ce moment là que je décide de
changer de changer mes croyances de
changer mes automatismes de faire un
travail de résilience une réparation qui
va me permettre d'avancer qui va me
permettre de savoir qui je suis et ce
que je veux faire de ma vie et comment y
arriver
et à ce moment là je réalise que les
choses commencent à avancer enfin et je
me dis que si moi j'ai pu le faire
bah ça peut marcher pour les autres et
en fait tout ça m'a permis de comprendre
que au cours de ma vie je me suis
toujours battu contre le monde entier
j'ai toujours été dans cette position de
victime et je me suis rendu compte que
en fait le combat le plus complexe le
combat le plus difficile qu'on va le
plus important de ma vie c'est pas
contre les autres c'est contre moi
contre toutes ces croyances contre tous
ses automatismes contre 7
tim isation en fait qui faisait de moi
une personne qui était inférieur à ce
que je pouvais être et donc j'ai décidé
de changer j'ai décidé de devenir une
meilleure version moi même et j'ai
compris que ce travail ne pouvait venir
que d'eux que de moi même et pas du
monde extérieur et que finalement toutes
les rencontres que j'ai faites que ce
soient les bonnes ou les mauvaises
en fait elles ont été utiles parce que
en fait j'ai jamais perdu j'ai toujours
gagné parce que en fait on perd jamais
soit on gagne soit on apprend voilà
[Applaudissements]